ces projets de la france intervient je
vais chose le jeu des castes le principe
prêter soit vous avez tous nouveaux quoi
oui très bon le principe est très simple
je pose une question à siri vous allez
mettre des castes donc personne ne
l'entend
ouais ça concernera l'un d'entre vous il
vous choisir avec une pièce voudrait
tirer à trévoux faire l'écart car les
pauvres filles vous saurez quelle est la
question face vous ne saurez jamais
d'accord attention vous n'entendez plus
rien arthur non plus c'est bon attention
j'ai les questions là sur mon téléphone
je suis très nouvelles technologies
cyril oui je vous pose tout de suite la
première question oui vous allez devoir
donner à pied c'est quelqu'un a remarqué
que nous on n'a pas de casque était pas
vous entendrez tous dans l'équipe cyril
d'après vous ouais dès que vous avez le
dos tourné des vous n'êtes pas et que
eux
d'après-vous parmi tous ces gens là
autour de la table donc vous occupez qui
vous critiquent le plus dès que vous
tournez le dos il n'y a pas réfléchi
longtemps
il part avec la pièce ça mais en général
une belle ambiance de merde
ouais bon encore lui
c'est peut-être sympa et ça peut être
spéciaux et pile ou face
il vous dira question façon là le saura
jamais ils allaient dans un cri face
c'est face on ne dit pas c'est façon
globale pour passer une autre question
ont passé une autre question cyril
attention remettez les casques
rapidement pile ou face cyril parmi tous
les gens autour de la table il ya même
un des patrons de des 8
sincèrement si vous étiez obligés de
vous faire greffer le visage de
quelqu'un autour de la table
quel est le dernier visage que vous
choisiriez
kluba zoulou pis la ville
bingo [ __ ] je veux juste bien la
question alors la question il m'a
demandé ça n'a rien à voir avec le
physique alors simplement c'est une
frère maher de l'ère de la ccba mairie
m'a demandé si j'étais obligé de faire
greffer le visage de quelqu'un qu'elle
serait la dernière personne
berti paiement là c'est qu'on la met pas
nos séries
c'est finalement joué tantôt
terminé mais je veux toi c'est toi que
je pose les questions au bon show
sinistre à la non mais un piment l'a
d'abord tu as mangé un pilon que c'est
d'ailleurs deux fois question voilà les
questions auxquelles la pièce j'ai dû me
remplit la fête on peut organiser la
ligue 1 dernière question se remettaient
tous les cas ça peut concerner n'importe
qui d'entre vous même vous arthur
attention faut faire pipi série la
dernière question mais des casques
gilets désilets attention dernière
question la voici
cyril way parmi tous les chroniqueurs
parmi eux arthur mettez le casque parmi
tous les gens autour de la table
sincèrement qui est ce que vous aimeriez
le moins voir à poil en loge vous
rentrez en loge vous tomber dessus
qu'elle ait su demeurer le moins à voir
pourquoi du poc
c'est frais c'est bien chez nous ce qui
s'est passé ce soir prochainement
vraiment tradition c'est pour la bonne
cause celle où gît à tous d'avoir été